We now develop a methodology for
finding the PDF of the sum
of two independent random
variables, when these random
variables are continuous
with known PDFs.
So in that case, Z will
also be continuous and
so will have a PDF.
The development is quite
analogous to the one for the
discrete case.
And in the discrete
case, we obtained
this convolution formula.
This convolution formula
corresponds to a summation
over all ways that a certain
sum can be realized.
In this picture, these are all
the ways that the sum of 3 can
be realized.
In the continuous case, the
different ways that the
constant sum can be realized
corresponds to a line.
So this is a line in which X
plus Y is equal to a constant.
And we need to somehow add over
all the possible ways
that the sum can be obtained,
add over all the
points on this line.
Now, when we're summing over all
the points of the line we
really need to employ
an integral.
And this leads to the following
guess for the formula.
Instead of having a summation,
we will have an integral.
And the integral is over all the
X, Y pairs whose sum is a
constant number, little z.
So we have here the
family recipe--
that sums are replaced by
integrals and PMFs are
replaced by PDFs.
So this formula is entirely
plausible.
And it is called the
continuous convolution formula.
What we want to do next is to
actually justify this formula
more rigorously.
We will use the following
trick.
We will first condition on the
random variable X, taking on a
specific value.
If we do this conditioning,
then the random variable Z
becomes little x plus Y. And
to make the argument more
transparent, we're going to look
first at the special case
where little x is let's
say, the number 3.
In which case our random
variable Z is
equal to Y plus 3.
Let us now calculate the
conditional PDF of Z in a
universe in which we are told
that the random variable X
takes on the value of 3.
Now, given that X takes on the
value of 3, the random
variable Z is the same as the
random variable Y plus 3.
And now we have the conditional
PDF of y plus 3
given X.
However, we have assumed that
X and Y are independent.
So the conditional PDF is going
to be the same as the
unconditional PDF of Y plus 3.
And we obtain this expression.
Now, what is this?
We know the PDF of Y. But now
we want the PDF of Y plus 3,
which is a simple version of a
linear function of a single
random variable Y. For a linear
function of this form,
we have already derived
a formula.
In the notation we have used
in the past, if we have a
random variable X, and we add
the constant to it, the PDF of
the new random variable is the
PDF of X but shifted by an
amount equal to b
to the right.
And that's what the shifting
corresponds to mathematically.
Now, let's us apply this
formula to the case
that we have here.
We need to keep track of
the different symbols.
So capital Y corresponds to X,
b corresponds to 3, little x
corresponds to Z. And by using
these correspondences, what we
obtain is f sub Y of this
argument, which is Z in our
case minus b, which
is 3 in our case.
And this is the final form for
the conditional density of Z
given that X takes
a specific value.
It's nothing more than the
density of Y, but shifted by 3
units to the right.
Let us now generalize this.
Instead of using X equal to 3,
let us use a general number.
And this gives us the more
general formula, that the
conditional PDF of Z given that
X takes on a specific
value is equal to--
just use little x here
instead of 3.
It takes this form.
So we do have now in our hands
a formula for the conditional
density of Z given X.
Since we have the conditional,
and we also know the PDF of X,
we can use the multiplication
rule to find the joint PDF of
X and Z. By the multiplication
rule, it is the marginal PDF
of X times the conditional PDF
of Z given X, which in our
case takes this particular
form.
And now that we have the joint
PDF in our hands, we can use
another familiar formula
that takes us from the
joint to the marginal.
It would take the joint PDF and
integrate with respect to
one argument, we obtain the
marginal PDF of the other
random variable.
Using this specific form that
we have for the joint PDF in
this formula, we have finally
obtained this expression.
This is the integral of the
joint PDF of X with Z
integrated over all xs.
And this proves this convolution
formula.
In terms of the mechanics of
carrying out the calculation
of the convolution, the
mechanics are exactly the same
as in the discrete case.
If you want to solve a problem
graphically, what you will do
is to take the PDF of Y, flip
it horizontally, and then
shift it by an amount of little
z, cross multiply
terms, and integrate them out.